Now in this problem, I want to think of a mass and pulling it back against a spring by a distance Δx.
I've told you what the spring constant is here.
When I release this mass it's going to go across this friction in this blue area,
over this rough surface where there is some force of friction (F = 1 N),
back towards this friction in this area, up to this curve ramp.
It's going to travel up, up, up, up, up, up, up and back down,
back over the area with friction, it's going to compress the spring, and so on.
The cycle will repeat many times until eventually well the mass will run out of energy
because every time the mass travels over this area of friction
well it's going to lose some of its kinetic energy.
It'll lose all of its kinetic energy. It'll go to 0, and the mass will have stopped somewhere on here.
Your task is to tell me where.
If we defined some coordinate x,
and this x goes from 0 at the beginning of this area with friction all the way to—
well the length is 0.8, so where's the mass when the motion stops?
And another interesting thing to think about, what's the maximum height that the mass ever reaches
when it launches off this ramp?
The point of this question is to get you thinking and talking about energy transitions
and what happens with friction.
There's no solution video, and I'm not even going to have you answer the question here.
What I want you to do is to see the thread in the link below this video,
and go there and talk about this question. Share you answers. Talk about your approach.